[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the
hogwarts express and the uk national
rail network
with a platform that's invisible
inaccessible to muggles and a rail line
that heads to a magical school in the
scottish highlands you probably won't be
surprised to hear me say that the
railway trip out to hogwarts is unusual
to say the least
trains play a pivotal part in harry
potter with platform nine and three
quarters and the hogwarts express both
playing a crucial role in harry's first
trip away from the dursleys and off into
the wizarding world
but have you ever wondered how this
magical railway ride fits into a
pre-existing national rail network the
uk national rail network to be specific
does the hogwarts express exist entirely
independently from the rest of these
trains or does it share some of the same
tracks does it transport some of the
same passengers
is the hogwarts express able to
magically avoid collisions what gives
from our perspective it all starts at
platform nine and three quarters at
king's cross station where students
board the hogwarts express a scarlet
steam engine transporting students to
and from hogwarts the platform can be
accessed by walking straight through the
barrier between platforms nine and ten
but you may have a bit of a hard time if
it's a your first go or b you're a
muggle
platform nine and three quarters was of
course filmed at king's tross station on
the edge of central london it's an
active railway station but at the real
station you will find that platforms 9
and 10 are separated by tracks before
filming platforms 4 and 5 were
renumbered 9 and ten and at the station
today you'll find the hidden access to
platform nine and three quarters
complete with half a luggage cart
disappearing into the wall
once you've made it past platform nine
and three quarters next you'll be
boarding the hogwarts express the train
runs between king's cross station and
hogsmeade station making the trip
approximately six times per year or more
if necessary it's on the hogwarts
express that harry's relationship begins
to blossom with the other two members of
the famous trio hermione granger and ron
weasley
once you finish your journey on the
train your next destination as a new
student is a school that you may have
heard of hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry but in order to answer the
question of how this railway network
fits in with the muggle networks we need
to dive deeper into the history of the
hogwarts express
thanks to pottermore we've got some
information that's not particularly well
known even to the bigger harry potter
fans when it occurred to the ministry
that transporting students to hogwarts
needed to be addressed then minister for
magic ottolene gamble came up with a
solution a daring and controversial
solution to the thorny problem of
transporting students was finally
suggested by minister for magic ottolene
gamble who was much intrigued by muggle
inventions and saw the potential in
trains where exactly the hogwarts
express came from has never been
conclusively proven
although it is a fact that there are
secret records at the ministry of magic
detailing a mass operation involving 167
memory charms and the largest ever mass
concealment charm performed in britain
the morning after these alleged crimes a
gleaming scarlet steam engine and
carriages astounded the villagers of
hogsmeade who had also not realized they
had a railway station while several
bemused muggle railway workers downing
crew spent the rest of the year
grappling with the uncomfortable feeling
that they had mislaid something
important
when ottolene gamble commandeered a
muggle train to serve as the new mode of
transport for hogwarts students
she also had constructed a small station
in the wizarding village of hogsmeade a
necessary adjunct to the train
the ministry of magic felt strongly
however that to construct an additional
wizarding station in the middle of
london would stretch even the muggles
notorious determination not to notice
magic when it was exploding in front of
their faces
it was evangeline orpington minister
from 1849 to 1855
who hit upon the solution of adding a
concealed platform at the newly
muggle-built king's cross station which
would be accessible only to witchers and
wizards
with this brief bit of history on the
hogwarts express i suspect that it
either connects onto a muggle train line
shortly after departing from king's
cross or it simply uses its own unique
line the entire way
perhaps even it's a bit of both
to defend point one it would make
perfect sense for witches and wizards to
utilize leverage the existing station's
infrastructure
why construct an entire railway line
when they can simply use what's already
there and cast somewhere in the vicinity
of 167 memory charms to conceal the work
done and achieve said alterations
with this approach all the ministry
would need to do is create a secret
platform then produce some sort of
concealed junction in a location that's
relatively inconspicuous and nearby the
train itself doesn't particularly stick
out or appear inherently magical so
there'd be no reason for them not to use
existing railway lines
as far as collisions with other trains
goes it just so happens that the
hogwarts express underwent several
magical modifications before being
approved by the ministry for school use
i hypothesized that these modifications
were put in place in order to address
this very issue
but i could also be way off the second
point however that the hogwarts express
operates on its own line entirely might
actually make more sense
one of the main pieces of rationale
behind my support for this theory is the
fact that hogsmeade had its own station
built under ottoleen gamble's
instruction a necessary adjunct to the
train
from my perspective there's absolutely
no way that the ministry of magic would
chance a muggle line's arrival in
hogsmeade as that would be a direct
infringement on the international
statute of secrecy which preserves the
divide harmony between muggle and
magical worlds the next argument for
this second theory is that no other
trains are ever mentioned running along
the scenic route of the hogwarts express
it seems as though the hogwarts express
runs along an exceptionally rural route
passing by seemingly very few cities and
towns
the train rattled onwards speeding them
out into open country they made regular
checks on the train as they flew further
and further north each dipped beneath
the cloud showing them a different view
london was soon far behind them replaced
by neat green fields which gave way in
turn to wide purplish moors villagers
with tiny toy churches and the great
city alive with cars like multi-colored
ants
this route provided the omission of
information pertaining to cities is due
to a lack of cities contradicts existing
northern mughal routes out of king's
cross towards scotland that in actuality
passed by many cities and towns
including peterborough durham edinburgh
etc the hogwarts express doesn't appear
to be on any sort of existing rail
network and i say this because no
railway stations are ever mentioned on
its journey with all of that said
perhaps the modifications to the train
by the ministry mentioned earlier were
focused more towards concealment rather
than collision avoidance i'd imagine
that a lone railway line heading towards
a magical school with no stops for that
matter would draw a considerable amount
of attention
to stop any awkward questions it would
be easier to just make the train
invisible to muggle's eyes
cue complex concealment charms
to construct the line which covers a lot
of ground i'd imagine that it would have
taken an awful lot of careful secretive
work
but for dire situations when curious
muggle eyes happened to witness what was
happening there's always the 167 memory
charms mentioned earlier but i do have
one more thing to add in various shots
in the films we see the hogwarts express
traveling across a bridge a bridge that
i happen to know something about
the bridge is known as the glenfinen
viaduct found in scotland it's located
on the west highland line in glenfinan
in vanessa scotland
it is the longest concrete railway
bridge in scotland at 416 yards 380
meters and crosses the river finnen at a
height of a hundred feet
the viaduct also overlooks the glenfenin
monuments and the waters of loxshiel
provided that we have visual proof of
the hogwarts express traveling across a
known bridge and not just random
countryside
evidence would suggest that the hogwarts
express does indeed travel across some
known railway lines
for that reason my final conclusion is
that the hogwarts express travels along
a bit of both
whichever way you break it down
implementing a wizarding transportation
system that's integrated with the muggle
world is no easy feat
the largest ever mass concealment charm
being performed is a testament to just
how seriously this matter was taken and
sometimes i just wonder why not flu
powder
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel did you
ever wonder about this question
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]